here is Donald Trump addressing this  issue of the values of his properties  see if you can make sense of this and  she said we're going to get him that her  whole campaign was based on that and  then she came after us we've been going  over this for years and I actually  thought because our values are really  high the company is great I built a  great company you take places like this  so many other places that I have like  this frankly I mean just the among the  finest places anyway you can't even  address the substance just he gets  locked into this my places are great in  the world I actually thought that they  would never bring a case and she brought  it and the reason I thought because she  didn't have a case uh I was of the  impression she wanted to settle but I  had a problem because how do you pay  something even if it's a small amount of  money if you're not guilty this was he  thought she was gonna just I mean it's  completely unintelligible folks